une
oui
l'épagneul breton fonce avec
détermination et boloni conviant obstiné
l'air de rien mais fon de compétences et
le gard ouailles ans on se demande nous
lie à cette joyeuse volonté cette
énergie est ce sens du moment populaire
parce que sympathique
il est très polyvalent
l'épagneul breton est le plus petit
chien d'arrêt des races monumental sa
taille est un sacré atout
en montagne en plein dans les bois les
marais il se faufile partout avec a
chuté l'instinct aux ordres le nez au
vent on ne donnera pas que ce chai
rustique soit rabelais et trapu à
physique plein de sens et de vigueur non
dénué d'élégance comme tous les
épagneuls le breton est un chien facile
et agréable qui s'adapte aux
circonstances pour êtes-vous il est
acteur tout d'aptitude dehors instinct
et flair remarquable tel incident et et
acharnement au travail dynamisme
il est la spontanéité même complice
débrouillards astucieux il réunit un
maximum de qualité pour un volume
minimum
deuxième race française en importance
l'épagneul breton se caractérise par sa
grande intelligence et sa vivacité mais
aussi par son caractère sportif et
travailleurs qui en font un des chiens
les plus robustes que l'on puisse
trouver en france
l'espagnol est effectivement le plus
populaire et le plus répandu des chiens
de chasse français
plus de cinq mille naissances ont été
enregistrées en france d'où un chef d'el
remarquable d'environ 60 à 65 milles
sujet l'évolution des naissances et
régulière les origines pour un épagneul
breton
c'est très très important n'achetez pas
un épagneul breton n'importe où il ya de
très très bons éleveurs un petit peu
partout en france et il ne faut pas
hésiter à se déplacer demander des
renseignements le club de l'épagneul
breton est là aussi pour vous en donner
et vous savez faut pas oublier que
c'était pagnol ses 12 ans dans votre vie
c'est des tas de bons souvenirs donc
n'achetez pas n'importe où et n'importe
comment
le revenez and culture
sur quels
paul ahyi convaincu
en plus de ses conseillers avisés lors
de l'acquisition du chiot l'éleveur doit
fournir son certificat de naissance à
l'âge adulte
le chien devra être examiné par un
expert confirma teurs afin que la
société centrale canine puisse établir
son pedigree il sera alors inscrit
définitivement au livre des origines
français
tous les espagnols sont des dons des
chiens de race continental qui a la
particularité d'être calme et très
affectueux je pense que
le peuple breton et parmi les espagnols
celui qui a le caractère le plus vif
c'est un chien plus vraiment agréable
avec vous dans vos sorties
même si vous ne cherchez pas vous pouvez
très bien prendre un épagneul breton
pour les promenades pour la la vie de
famille disons c'est vraiment le chien
agréable et complet il veuille breton et
attentionné que le caractère vif joyeux
enjoué et
c'est vraiment sa particularité c'est
qu'il doit le caractérise et c'est un
chien qui est rempli de qualité et en
plus c'est un chien vraiment super sympa
l'épagneul breton être appuyé rabelais
petit chien élégant très vigoureux son
corps s'inscrit dans un carré on dit
qu'il écope en mouvement il est
énergique plein de sens la teinte est
arrondie avec un crâne de longueur
moyenne aux parois latérales marqué et
arrondies la taille de l'épagneul breton
est comprise entre 46 et 51 cm pour un
poids d'environ 15 kg pour le mal et 13
kg pour la femelle
le stop est bien marqué mais incliné le
chanfrein et droit ou recourbé la truffe
est bien ouverte un port du 2 est en
principe assorti à la couleur la plus
foncée de la robe
les lèvres sont fines remonter la lèvre
supérieure dépassant très peu de la
lèvre inférieure
les yeux sont vifs et expressif d'une
couleur ambre foncé en harmonie avec la
robe les yeux clairs dit d'oiseaux trois
sont un défaut
les oreilles planté o sont plutôt
courtes légèrement arrondi peu frangé
quoique bien garnie de poils ondulé
l'encolure est de moyenne longueur sans
fanon est bien dégagé les épaules qui
sont obligés muscler la poitrine et
profonde descendants pleinement au
niveau du coude le dos et court jamais
ans les avec un garrot bien assortir le
rail court large et vigoureux les
hanches plus basque le garrot et
saillantes
arrivant à la hauteur du dos la coupe
est légèrement fuyante et les flancs
remonter sans excès
les membres antérieurs son droit fin et
vigoureux est peu fournie en franges en
du lait est membre post ayant des
cuisses larges traits descendu et très
musclé avec le jarret la pointe de la
fesse sur la même verticale et pied sont
bien serré n'iront ni non pas la queue
et droite ou tombante si le chien n'est
pas un amour toujours courtes pas plus
de dix centimètres souvent forcés elle
se termine par une mèche de poils
le poil et fin sans excès plutôt plat ou
légèrement ondulés la couleur de la robe
bicolore blanc orange blanc marron ou
encore blanc noir elle peut être aussi
tricolore ou juan et de l'une de ses
couleurs
au milieu du siècle dernier les races
des bagnoles n'étaient pas fixés comme
actuellement
il existait dans l'hexagone un grand
nombre de variétés régionales voire
local des bagnoles et il ne fait pas de
doute que la bretagne en comptait
quelques unes à elle seule le premier à
avoir cité cette race fut un britannique
le révérend davis dans un ouvrage
consacré à la chasse en basse bretagne
il est donc certain qu'au xviiie siècle
il existait dans la partie nord de
l'europe une variété d pagnol à laquelle
s'apparente le breton pour certains il
descendrait du chien d'oisel dont parle
le fameux chasseur médiévale casto fébus
au début du xvème siècle
selon d'autres cinéphiles il serait issu
du web springer spaniel monsieur winch
lui citant un poème de pien fait
remonter l'origine de l'épagneul breton
à l'époque romaine ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'en 1907 en bretagne sous la pulsion
de monsieur hainaut fut créé le club de
l'épagneul breton à courte que naturel
en 1908 à l'exposition canine de loudéac
le premier standard codifiant la race
fut élaborée
l'éducation de l'épagneul breton ne pose
pas de problème particulier
gary est intelligent il caractère qui
est facile un peu têtu sans être propre
obstiné et il n'est pas non plus trop
sensible c'est un chien qui acceptent
l'éducation qu'on lui apporte
et disons que son côté affectif et
spontanée fait que son indication de
cause pas de réel problème il faut tout
de même se souvenir que le chien
appartient à une espèce différente et
que les mots n'ont pas de sens pour lui
à preuve c'est que nous avons dû
apprendre un autre jeune chiot son nom
mais alors ce qu'il faut pour en faire
surtout c'est de coller le nez du petit
chien dans le tipi alors ça c'est une
hérésie
cc c'est dommage c'est une façon de
c'est un risque qu'on prend deux
traumatisés
ce petit ça rit ça se fait pas comme ça
pour l'éducation ce jeune chien ne sais
pas mais c'était c'est logique ne sais
pas ce que c'est qu'un marchand l'aise
donc allez-y tout doucement n'y allait
pas brutalement qu'ils gardent un
mauvais souvenir de cette laisse c'est à
dire que quand ce chien vous allez le
maître en laisse vous le tirer
progressivement vers vous en le
caressant lui donnant un petit biscuit
et ça c'est une bonne base
ce qui est bien plus important que les
mots c'est l'intonation et plus encore
que l'intonation ce sont les gestes
joindre le geste à la parole pour
essayer de faire comprendre quelque
chose à son chien c'est véritablement la
meilleure méthode ensuite le rappelle
quand vous lâcher dans la nature
surtout pour le rappeler n'hésitez pas à
vous accroupir et ça c'est une très
bonne chose
il ya quand même un truc dans leur appel
qui est très important c'est la position
accomplir un chien ce revient toujours
plus facilement sur une personne qui est
accroupi que sur une personne qui
restent debout planté qui est plus
agressive vis-à-vis du chien qu'une
personnes accroupies qui est beaucoup
plus sympathique et qui se met à sa
hauteur et qui fait que le chien revient
éventuellement lui sauter dessus il
mettait pas de vous baisser quand il
revient vers vous vous lui donnez une
récompense et ça c'est bon ça c'est très
très bien la meilleure récompense et la
caresse si vous avez une friandise
ou de ces c'est bien aussi mais faut pas
abuser de la friandise patio la caresser
bien suffisant on ne caressent jamais
trop son chien
pour le marchepied éviter que chien tir
vous prenez une laize et les meilleurs
l'est c'est bien le collier avec la lèze
régime c'est-à-dire que quand il veut
tirer vous le ramenez a écrit fermeté au
pied c'est à dire que c'est pas le chien
qui vous promène c'est vous qui
promenait le chien ça c'est la base
qu'on peut faire à partir de trois mois
jusqu'à six mois
beaucoup de personnes qui ont un
épagneul breton pour faire un chèque
pour payer mais principalement les
maillots de bâton est fait pour les
achats il est né pour ça est faux car
entre chiens et chats bon pour le gibier
la sortie sur le terrain il faut pas
hésiter à les sortir sur le terrain à
partir de 6 mois et demi mais surtout et
ça je le précise bien ne pas leur faire
entendre un coup de feu dans le vie ceux
ci voulaient si vous leur faites
entendre le coup de feu avant la passion
n'importe quel chien d'ailleurs ne
comprennent pas ce que vous leur
demanderez il faut d'abord les
passionnés leur faire entendre le coup
de feu une fois la passion acquise et ça
c'est très très bon à partir du moment
où on commence à mettre logis en
présence de gibier il faut pas faire
d'erreur impasse que nous
n'importe quel n'importe quelle faute si
vous voulez peut être grave pour le
comportement du chien par rapport au
comportement du vivier par la suite le
le chien ne doit jamais avoir peur du
gibier il doit toujours aller en
confiance prendre là
la connaissance du gibier avec son nez
c'est à dire prendre d'émanations il
doit toujours
garder le maximum de son de son envie
est là il faut canaliser le chien mais
il faut pas faut pas faire d'erreur pour
le rappeur s'ils ont leurs apports
naturels continuer mais sinon pas le
rapport naturel ne pas les obliger ne
pas oublier que l'épagneul breton est
avant tout un chien d'arrêt et le
rapport peut venir après mais vous savez
faut pas trop demander un jeune chien le
chien commence à être à maturité 10 ans
vers 200 avant c'est tout un
apprentissage
la majorité des éleveurs pense que
l'épagneul breton peut chasser tout
gibier à l'exception toutefois du grand
gibier pour lequel il n'est pas conçu
alors l'épagneul breton est vraiment un
chien très très polyvalent on peut se
servir de l'épagneul breton aussi bien
en plaine aussi bien aux marées et au
bois ce chien et passe partout et c'est
vraiment un chien très très polyvalent
sterk en plein dans les grandes plaines
ou céréalière il se comporte très bien
sûr le perdreau mais quand vous êtes au
bois mais il se comporte à merveille
pour la bécasse le faisan et c'est un
chien aussi qu'ils se comportent très
très bien aux mares dire qu'on peut se
servir de l'épagneul breton pour chasser
la bécassine éventuellement aller à la
hutte chasser le canard à la passe et
c'est vraiment le chien complet
l'épagneul breton et polyvalence et
c'est ce que l'on dit ce style a
toujours caractérisé ces drass sa
particularité c'est un chien
qui courent trapu vif énergique son
modèle réduit fait qu'il passe
facilement dans les terrains difficiles
et c'est un chef généreux courageux à
l'action et beaucoup de décisions sur
les gibiers
sur le gibier sauvage et qui se défend
très bien c'est un chien qui a titré
ruse est très malin pour ce qui est de
son travail sur le terrain la quête face
au vent et chez lui quelque chose de
naturel qu'on peut travailler mais qui
est quand même qu'il a deux
de manière naturelle il a un excellent
des c'est peut-être sa particularité
qu'il fait qu'il sait très bien démêler
les différentes émanations qui
qui se présente devant lui et
c'est pourquoi généralement sur le
gibier difficile c'est vraiment un chien
qui a beaucoup de décisions et qui s'en
sortent très bien
un fils triol mot anglais qui signifie
concours de travail
c'est l'occasion pour les bretons n'y
ait mordu de comparer leurs meilleurs
chiens en vue de la reproduction
tout propriétaire de chien peut
participer à l'épreuve à partir du
moment où l'un chinois ce qui est qu'il
trouve excellent qu'il entraîne qu'il
prépare pour justement participé à ces
différents fils la situation volcanique
n'organise différence des preuves pour
toutes les races de chiens d'arrêt les
règlements sont les mêmes pour les
épagneuls bretons que pour toutes les
autres races continental li a d'une part
les épreuves de printemps qui se court
sur couples de perdrix au printemps dans
la période de mars et avril
dans ce type d'épreuve on demande aux
chiens de deux de quêter est de trouver
le gibier de l'arrêter mais le tir et le
gibier n'est pas tiré il y à l'automne
pendant la période d'ouverture de la
chasse les concours de ce qu'on appelle
de cette pratique ou le même travail et
demander mais en plus le gibier tir on
demande le rapport le rapport des lieux
du gibier par le chien non ces
différentes épreuves de
les classifications fonds données qui
vont du très bon à l'excellent et
lorsque le parcours est vraiment
excellent et sans faute
on attribue ce qu'on appelle ses as été
c'est-à-dire certificat d'aptitude au
championnat de travail et un certain
nombre de ca c'etait donne le titre de
champion de travail mais disons que le
but de toutes ces épreuves ces deux îles
de trouver des géniteurs et qui sont les
plus représentatifs de la race de
manière à améliorer les races canines et
en particulier les payements temps on
peut être tenté par l'idée de présenter
son épagneul breton lors d'une
exposition canine
il faut s'y préparer avec soin à prendre
certaines règles indispensables au bon
déroulement des opérations et habitués
le chien à bien se comporter lorsqu'il
sera jugé il est tout à fait
indispensable que le chien soit détendu
et calme pour la présentation la peur et
la nervosité étant considérés comme des
défauts de même le chien devra être
habitué à être manipulées à se laisser
faire
le juge devra examiner le sujet sur
toutes les coutures il doit être
habituée à toutes les épreuves afin
qu'ils ne sont en effet pas et que tout
se passe dans le calme a pris acquis au
cours d'une exposition canine de beauté
ou de travail n'a pour le mettre une
valeur honorifique mais pour le chien il
atteste de sa conformité aux standards
et peu le promouvoir en vue d'une
reproduction destiné à préserver le
patrimoine génétique et morphologiques
de la race
l'épagneul breton et normand de toilette
pas excéder toi tout seul quand on
revient de la chasse dont on peut à la
rigueur le procès avec une serpillière
ou alors lui donner un petit coup de
brosse si on habite un appartement mais
vite et quand même que salir les eaux
des normands jamais le deuil
en fait ce bémol le pen breton est un
chien très rustique et qui demandent pas
de soins particuliers
le un tas de bon brossage
très régulièrement de face que pour le
débarrasser mais de différents parasites
qui pu récolter pendant la chasse suffi
et c'est un chien qui ne pose pas de
problème particulier au niveau des
politiciens sachent y est très rustique
mais doit-on voir une exposition mais
faut quand même le toiletter un petit
peu c'est à dire le mot copé un tout
petit peu les poils sur les oreilles ou
ceux nés autour des oreilles d'une
petite toilette mais très rarement
l'épagneul breton a les oreilles
tombantes
il faut les nettoyer régulièrement c'est
non seulement une nécessité pour éviter
tous les problèmes nos titres mais c'est
aussi un excellent moyen de le manipuler
dans tous les sens et l'habituer à se
laisser soigner
à l'aide d'un coton ouaté imbibé de
sérum physiologique
il faut nettoyer le coin des yeux pour
enlever les sécrétions l'étang de
l'épagneul breton doivent être
surveillés entretenues afin d'éviter la
formation de tartre qui peut provoquer
déjà j vite ou pour le moins une
mauvaise haleine désagréable
l'avis du chiot épagneul breton et on
commence bien évidemment dans le ventre
de sa mère lors d'une gestation qui va
durer 60 à 62 jours une chienne épagneul
breton mais ben en moyenne 7 à 10 jours
pour les chiots qui ne laisse pas à nour
c'est à dire sans qu il est de coutume
chez les paniers pour tombe de 17 clubs
dans les premiers jours de la vie à
partir de la quatrième semaine en cour a
procédé au sevrage progressif des chiots
haye est nécessaire chez les bagnoles
breton d'essayer de se garer sur la team
mentaux dans la mesure où ces traces
étant très prolifique cette addition
et bien cela est très demandeur pour la
mer vers la sixième semaine on procédera
à une première vaccination contre la
parvovirose gastro entérite hémorragique
qui fait parfois des ravages chez les
chiots et ce n'est que quinzaine de
jours plus tard vers la 8ème 9ème
semaines que l'on mettra véritablement
en oeuvre le plan de vaccination de
l'animal contre la parvovirose
la maladie de carré les pratiques de rue
bar la leptospirose et bien sûr la démo
vous allez faire l'acquisition de votre
chiot est payé bien sûr à ce qu'il
dispose de tous ses papiers qui atteste
que les vaccinations ont été mises en
oeuvre durant cette première phase de sa
vie c'est à cette époque et quatre ans
qu'il va falloir le vermifuge et car les
maires lui transmette un certain nombre
de parasites en particulier digestif
contre lesquels il est nécessaire de le
prévenir convenablement vacciné et
vermifugé le chiot épagneul breton entre
maintenant dans sa phase de croissance
et même si sochaux est suffisamment
robuste pour que celle ci ne présente
jamais de mon problème eh bien il est
nécessaire pour le propriétaire d'être
quelque peu attentifs à des courbes de
croissance typ à bien se souvenir que ce
chiot va devenir adulte vers l'âge de 12
à 14 mois et pesé alors 15 à 18 kg est
également être attentif à ne pas lui
demander de travailler trop tôt à ne pas
lui imposer des ford exercice trop
brusque forcer à faire descendre des
escaliers par exemple de façon rapide ce
sont des choses qui peuvent nuire à sa
croissance et en particulier à la bonne
harmonie de son squelette
dès lors que le chiot épagneul breton
devient adulte et il est nécessaire de
se rappeler que ce chien est un chien le
sport un chien de travail que donc il va
falloir l'emmener à la campagne ce qui
peut lui poser un certain nombre de
petits problèmes parfois car il a les
oreilles tombantes il peut donc s'y
immiscer des et pillé cette petite
barbiche de graminées qui vont rentrer
dans l'oreille et poser quelques
troubles donc chaque fois qu'on va les
emmener promener le chien la campagne
a bien nettoyé à bien regarder les
oreilles après cette promenade même
chose pour les espaces interdigitaux
entre les doigts du chien il sera
également nécessaire au retour de cette
promenade est bien de veiller enlever
les critiques qui peuvent sévir dans un
certain nombre de régions dans la mesure
où ces sticks sont parfois un des agents
qui vont transmettre une maladie
parasitaire sanguine qui s'appelle la
piroplasmose et contre laquelle
maintenant on peut vacciner
l'épagneul breton est un chasseur
habitué à l'eau et au froid c'est
également un chien qui craint
relativement la chaleur alors qu'il fait
très chaud il faudra veiller un
abonnement régulier ne jamais le laisser
en pleine chaleur dans une voiture et
puis toujours mieux réserver un coin
d'ombré dans le jardin de manière à ce
qu'ils ne souffrent pas acceptable
quelle chaleur du perthois les gens
niveau
la bonne santé d'un chien que le
l'épagneul breton et bien c'est beaucoup
d'exercice et puis aussi être très
attentif à son alimentation car c'est un
chien qui a facilement membres
l'épagneul breton est un chien en russie
qu'on a coutume de dire chez luc qu'on
appétit veulent tout va vers
l'alimentation au revers un caractère
primordial dans tous les domaines de la
prévention
cette alimentation elle commenté la
période de gestation dès la grossesse
pour la chienne durant laquelle pendant
les dernières semaines de sa grossesse
mettra en oeuvre une alimentation un
petit peu enrichi en protéines et puis
enrichit également quantitativement de
l'ordre de 25% de plus que le besoin
d'entretien normal de l'année
les chiots et tu en es ma chienne à les
allaiter valeur dépensé beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de protéines pour
produire son lay faut à ces périodes lui
fournir un aliment complet c'est qu'ils
soient hyper concentré au plan
énergétique et au plan protéique la
période du sevrage qui se produit vers
l'âge de 4 semaines chez ces chauvet
nécessité de leur distribuer très
progressivement une brouilly sevrage qui
va permettre d'assurer la transition
entre les maternelles élément c'est que
l'on va mettre en oeuvre de préférence
durant la période de croissance celle-ci
se caractérise en là encore par une
augmentation du besoin en protéines et
en minéraux
l'alimentation sèche en croquer est
toujours préférable durant la période de
croissance car d'une part ces aliments
sont généralement mieux adaptés
dépression' helmand aux besoins
spécifiques du chiot à cette période et
d'autre part ils évitent des
surconsommations de la part du sio qui
ne font que conditionner l'apparition de
problèmes d'obésité lorsque l'animal
deviendra adulte à l'âge adulte et bien
ce chiot quittera son aliment en
spécifique croissance pour venir à
consommer un aliment soit de type
entretien dès lors qu'il sera en
appartement et qu'il ira se promener
simplement de temps à autre en ville ou
un aliments pour chiens actif dans la
mesure où on emmènera ce chien à la
chasse ou bien où il fera pratiquer un
certain nombre de sports canins durant
la phase de croissance on pourra
commencer vers l'âge de 5 à 6 semaines
par la mise en oeuvre de trois repas
quotidiens pour ensuite en venir à 2
repas 1 matin et le soir toujours à
leurs pics toujours dans la même gamelle
et puis vers l'âge de six mois se
contenter d'un seul retard d'autres
préférant en soirée en fin d'après midi
et là encore toujours à la même place
toujours en galère contrairement à ce
que l'on peut croire et bien que ce soit
un chasseur l'épagneul breton comme tous
les autres chiens n'a pas un besoin
spécifique de consommer des eaux
lorsqu'on donne des eaux un chien etc
soit des eaux de grosse taille ou que ce
soit des carcasses de poulets par
exemple eh bien tout ce que l'on fait
finalement même si l'on amuse le chien
c'est de prendre le risque de le
constipé dans les 48 heures qui suivent
et ça généralement un chien n'aime pas
trop et puis lorsqu'on donne des hôtes
de lapin ou des carcasses de lapin et
bien le risque de vol en france et un
risque de perforation soit de
l'oesophage soit de l'estomac soit de
l'intestin doc la distribution d eau et
bien à nantes
n'est pas une nécessité c'est même
plutôt quelque chose qui risque d'être
nuisible à notre chien
voilà un épagneul breton plein de malice
et d'astuces qui ajoutée à toutes ses
autres qualités font de lui un chien
particulièrement efficace bien que ce
soit un chasseur dans l'âme il sait être
joueur doux et affectueux son
originalité c'est la coexistence de
double aspiration à la vie de chien
d'arrêt et celle de chêne compagnie il
est attachant et attaché à ses maîtres
bref le parcours sans faute pour ce
compagnon polyvalent dont le caractère
les aptitudes et la taille n'ont jamais
cessé d'être ses principaux atouts il
s'adapte à toutes les circonstances
que cela soit à la chasse ou dans la vie
civile il est tout simplement
remarquable
si vous ne le faites pas chasser il ne
vous en voudra pas partout il est
heureux enfin surtout ami
on
tous
m